hello everyone and welcome to what is
probably the last game will be showing
from the Cote d'Ivoire a rapid and blitz
tournament it's Hikaru Nakamura with the
white pieces against the Egyptian
Grandmaster Bassam Amin and we already
seen one game although it was from the
rapid section where I mean won a very
nice game against Nakamura so here's
Nakamura as the opportunity to for a
revenge without further ado let's check
out the game it's very nice and it
features one move both of them missed
and it you will have a very nice
opportunity also to add to figure out
which move that is so let's check it out
Nakamura opens with Knight to f3 we have
the ready opening night to have sex with
b3 now g6 both players ready to
fianchetto their dark square Bishop to
Bishop g7 d4 with castles III and now d6
Bishop to e2 nakamura prepares the
castle 9b d7 we have castles rook to e8
preparing e5 and here there are a lot of
moves that were played here like c4
Knight B to d2 was played here but the
c4 was played here
d5 was played here but Nakamura goes for
a4 and this is now a new move in this
particular line and it's only moved 8 so
very exciting with a5 not allowing
White's do at any point develop further
on the Queen side would be 4 and here we
have rook to e1 we have c6 by black
Bishop to f1 and now comes c5 as
Nakamura allowed it of course I mean
doesn't want to disappoint to remain on
e7 as it is a backwards born with D
captures on e5 d captures on e5 and not
Knight 2 a 3 and here of course the
knight now prevent some black from going
b5 but also has hopes of going at Knight
to c4 and here I mean it really takes
initiative he pushes efore forces
nakamura as nicely to retreat with
Knight d2 and now comes Knight to d5
offering a trade of dark square bishop
switch nakamura goes for will the shock
after sin g7 king captures and now
Knight d2 c 4 and here we have Queen to
f6 so as you can see it's a very dynamic
opening black not really having any
problems with the development of his
pieces
the knight is excellently placed on d5
this net can go
v6 if further exchanges are required if
can go to e5 this bishop can be
developed the e6 f5 doesn't really
matter all the rooks both rooks can come
into play and black really solved all of
his opening problems so nakamura goes
Queen to b4 he realizes that black has
too much activity and he offers the
trade of Queens we have queen capture
some d4e captures on d4 and now Knight 7
back to f6 both blacks Knights are now
very nicely placed on b5 and f6 now the
bishop can come into play and the rooks
will be connected and they're ready to
also join the game with Knight to e5 by
Nakamura and now you can see that the
white only has a light square bishop and
for the moment there's a really no good
way to to get rid of this night you can
go something like Knight to d7 or g4 to
offer a trade as the knight is well
needed the guard de for pawn from the
rook so at first with Bishop to f5 a
nice move with defense of the e4 pawn
also now the rooks are connected with
night 8 to c4 if now this Knight gets
traded off this knife can take its place
and also nicely eyeing that b6 square
and pressuring the a 5 point so this
rook can for the moment can't really
enter the game we have looked east 6 and
now comes Knights the e3 hoping to win
the bishop here so Knight captures on e3
with F captures an e3 and now just h5
preventing any h3g for ideas with Bishop
to c4 now attacking I mean rook rook to
e7 and now comes a move that is well
that's basically a big blunder but to no
one realized that here it's important to
play Bishop to e2 or f1 but Hiro
Nakamura played look e to f1 and it's
well it's a move that basically loses
the game but it's a hard to to pinpoint
why especially in a blitz game but you
know you're in your own home comfortable
hopefully you know in front of a big
screen or or on your smartphone doesn't
really matter but you have time to pause
the video so feel free to do so and try
to find the idea both of them missed in
this game I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to
congratulations you are an excellent
trapper of knights well or are you but I
will explain that the idea is Knight to
d5 and now you can see that all of the
squares that the knight can retreat to
are covered f6 is the threat and the
knight can go here the pawn covers that
the pawn covers this pawn covers this
and Bishop covers this so f6 is coming
and there's nothing you can do to
prevent it if you play Bishop captures
pawn captures now okay Bishop no longer
occupies the c4 squared but now this
spawn again guards the the story in the
d4 square and the knight is trapped
there's no saving this night there is
sorry sorry about that now there is one
possibility you can try after the C
capture Sun d5 you could try something
like g4 it is a well it's a very crazy
line but it does save you the night but
it will also lose you the game but we
will show it just to show that you are
able to save the night H captain g4 now
rook to f4 and now indeed if f6 comes
Knight can capture on g4 but the black
is just gonna go look to h8 and after
any move why does let's say C for now
you're gonna go f6 and now after this
trade Knight captures here you're gonna
go look to h4 now pin the night and
after something like h3 you're gonna go
rook captures on h3 King to have two
defending this pawn here and now just
work the c7 and black will have such a
dominant position that he should very
quickly even even win it a due to the
very unpleasant position of the White
King after the Queen side position opens
the rook can also enter the game and it
will be over very quickly so although
you can save the night so that's why I
said or are you but you will end up with
a losing position but doesn't really
matter as both of them missed it with
rook a to d8 by I mean and now comes h3
preparing g4 so I mean prevents it with
h4 by I mean c3 now and the now comes
Knight to d5 going for the c3 and III
pawn so you do have to trade bishop for
night here Bishop captures pawn captures
and now comes c4 nakamura also not
interested in having backwards see pawns
with f6 finally Knight to g4 Bishop
captures Bishop captures pawn captures
and now rook to c7 preparing to double
up on the C file and you know wreak
havoc along the sea line and here you
could go something like c5 close the
position and then maybe hope for
something like rook F to the other
Brooke can come to f1 and you can do
some pressure along the F file but
Nakamura isn't interested in that he
just goes C capture Sun d5 and now he
maybe was hoping for rook captures and
then just rook a to C 1 but I mean
doesn't waste time capturing the double
D pawn instead he goes for the active
rook to c3 and here it just seems that
it was necessary to put this pawn all
the way to c5 capturing here and
allowing Luke to c3
just looks like nakka nakka more under
estimating his well opponent but you
know you just don't underestimate
another grandmaster in a Brooks end game
doesn't really matter how much
fire-rated you are but okay now when a
comer goes rook a to C 1 with rook
captures and e3 eliminating this very
important base of the pawn chain with g5
by Nakamura and not just F captures and
g5 not really caring as any threats such
as maybe Roxy 7 care King h6 and rook f7
what ideas of checkmate are easily
preventable with just going G fo a g4
and another King can escape via the g5
square so here Nakamura played rook F to
e 1 we have a trade route captures rook
captures and now rook captures on d5
rook captures on e4 and now we have this
broken for an endgame
where I mean is up upon its a GG pawn
but still very important point to be up
King to f6 he now starts bringing his
King into the game and Nakamura's rook
will be very passive
especially since it has to remain there
to keep an eye on the d4 pawn we have
king to f2 now comes King to a5
attacking the rook came to f3 defending
and now just b6 improving the position
before doing anything rash with King -
III white doesn't have a pawn move so he
does have to move the King if he moves
the rook
he's just gonna he's just gonna lose
this pawn so we have King to e3 and now
G for preparing h3 to create a passport
also if if captures this will on double
blacks Jeep on we have looked back to eh
and the now comes h3 and here instead of
capturing Nakamura decides to play g3
which automatically creates a past h1
but at least you will be able to keep an
eye on it from behind we have King back
to f6 now comes rook the c8 and here you
could go for Luke to d6 and not allowing
something like check and captures but I
mean I mean calculate properly and he
sees that he is much faster than
Nakamura so look to a5 and active move
going for Luke to f3 check which would
eliminate this pawn and then well the
the pawn majority just keeps marching
forward with kinky for napkins rook to
a3 and now d5 now white is hoping to
push this pawn all the way as soon as
possible
with rook captures and g3 and now first
came to f4 kicking the row back with
rook to g1 and now comes Luke to h8 not
allowing the pawns to be pushed any
further but now comes g5 forcing the
white king away from the pawn mass as
you cannot go to f3 or g3 with rook to
King to e4 and now before pushing the
pawns we have just looked he one check
King to d4 and here I mean just push g3
and it was in this position that he Cara
Nakamura resigned the game once again
against his well Egyptian opponent that
that he underestimated by why not
pushing that c5 own but rather capturing
on d5 so why did Nakamura resigned well
there's all not all that much you can do
here and just g2 g1 is coming if you
capture the pawn just g2 g3 and here you
just
Queen with check so we have to capture
rook captures and now you are nowhere
near queening that pawn you can't even
enter the position with your king so
it's basically pointless
so after g3 nakamura resigns and then
yet another excellent victory for Bassam
Amin who after the
in rapid section of this Cote d'Ivoire
the tournament finished in last place
but he did have two excellent games
against Nakamura so he won against
Nakamura in the rapid he won against
Nakamura in the blitz and the third game
he played against Nakamura having the
black pieces that game ended in a draw
so out of three games two and a half
points against Nakamura the third
highest rated blitz player in the world
definitely an achievement for the
Egyptian Grandmaster and here we have a
nice photo by Leonard Otis sorry not
that where he is giving interview for
well I can only imagine the the local
media some of you may even know which
media it is but yeah there we have it
and before the tournament even started I
watched an interview with Bassam I mean
he said that every game he was watching
the Grantchester and he was very much
looking forward to playing with the DC
legends so to say and well seen it
seemed like a very very humble guy very
down-to-earth gentleman and I would
recommend you to watch that interview I
just can't I just don't know where I
where I've seen it it was probably dude
you know in the middle of the Ranchester
broadcast so if anyone has a link to
that or knows where it is do do comment
in the description below and do comment
in the comments I will pin your comments
give it a heart so everyone else can see
the interview if you are interested in
that so now that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Paul given sending sheesh tofu Banach
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
definitely continue in the capablanca
saga all the way up until probably ulti
box no way championship and then we're
going to of course cover that so thank
you all I will see you soon have an
excellent rest of your day